[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
fire
good morning very early I woke up at 3
o'clock today and we are now over on the
North Shore of Oahu and we are going on
a swim with the sharks 100% guarantee
this is what we're gonna be filming the
sharks with today I've got the GoPro
Hero 60 here and the rx0
why I'm bringing both is I'm not sure
because I have a problem and I just want
to test them out and see which one looks
better under water
we did this for the first time how long
ago was like four or five about four
years ago I can look it up exactly when
that was where I choose walking down the
shore dive in headfirst down to the
ocean floor to compromise referred
fireflies
we were not shooting in 4k iPhone we
have to go pace on the waterproof case
and yeah we did I think I was still
using that little Canon camera there to
mess around in the scene while we while
he's he's big Wow we're about headed
guys how's my look I'm kind of scared
[Music]
Oh save souls
finding hidden caves although wet stones
shaped by the oceans things we have to
do with all this is quite the experience
my mass keeps filling with water every
time I go under waters if you see
anything
[Music]
wish
well that's it breanne says she doesn't
get seasick but apparently you do yeah
it happens
I started feeling not so well towards
the end of this little boat ride we're
back on land I'm on ginger-ale duty my
tummy tickles
oh excuse me ma'am were you just on a
shark excursion yes thank you but they
had ginger ale on the boat really yeah
so many people on that boat were puking
like everyone whenever I hear puke I
wanna puke and everybody was puking this
is Leonard it is a famous bakery and
there he's really good
what do they think mussels malasadas and
we're gonna time the first time let's
see here super culture oh my gosh
they're super warm you might be careful
but you have to know it's just minimal
is just the donut Oh
[Music]
I didn't have it's a go cup BRE this is
what I've resorted to we're on our way
to a hike and if you don't know guess
what we're in Hawaii breeze driving no
one trusts me
let's let's go to the mic like I don't
want to put this coffee like it is not
made for this vehicle
[Music]
you guys look guys I'm bleeding out I'm
bleeding out I'm hurt
I dropped my camera almost fell into my
coffee and then I cracked the little
protective screen that I have on and
then I slipped my finger across the
glass and then I cut myself oh I'm
bleeding out I'm bleeding out forget I'm
injured what are we gonna do pull it out
I got to get some more blood out so I
can show Genna to make it look like I'm
injured nobody saw it
I got an injury Lum think I need it
we've got the bugs I could show Jenna
how do you see it I give these real
hearts and blood will come out
[Music]
[Applause]
we just stopped at the valley of the
temple in this place is so beautiful you
guys might recognize this from many
different movies was this in lost yeah
it was like a wedding scene I meant to
look it up it shocked right now
these fish are human I think in the
entire world it is the most beautiful
ranch there's over 4,000 acres and they
have shot so many films here I'm pretty
sure you guys have seen so many of them
we also did a really amazing tour here
back in October going to hop on this
boat and go a little small tiny cool
Island it's a really bad idea
so thankfully we're not moving I mean
it's definitely possible but I would not
[Music]
[Applause]
time about some attempt a really fun
drone shot I basically want to fly it
through this little boat and up and away
so let's hope that it works
i'ma try to I'm gonna do one basing me
in the way
[Music]
guys thank you so much for watching at
this vlog it was basically it seems like
almost six months in the making
I love this place and if you guys are
ever in Oahu I definitely recommend you
have to check it out it is just
incredibly breathtaking the views the
scenery and all of the people here are
so nice that it's such an experience
that I hope that one day you guys could
also experience it too but now that's it
that's the end of the vlog I'll see you
guys later
[Music]